when i dropped out of high school i
worked out i kind of worked at the surf
shop you know if you hang out the surf
shop and you're supposed to be at school
you better be sweeping the floors or
[ __ ] cleaning the shaping bay or
doing something productive you know to
help out the shop
so i ended up meeting this guy who was
working construction who lived at the
surf shop and he got me a construction
job
okay so i was making [ __ ] pretty good
money and i wasn't even like 18. i think
i just turned 18
and i and i got my first job and on a
construction site doing track homes in
lacosta all those alga houses
in la costa i built all those so i
helped build i was the laborer
good so but [ __ ] dude you guys are gonna
love this one
so i was killing it right
and then the guy who
the guy who um
got me the job got fired because he ran
over a fire extinguisher with the petty
bones like a big forklift
so they're like [ __ ] poopies he kind of
taught you how to drive the paddy bone i
was like yeah i can drive the thing you
know this huge ass heavier machinery
i'm [ __ ] driving around picking up
nails and [ __ ] plywood on the roofs
like i'm killing it and then they bring
in this new pedi bone and i wasn't used
to it and you have to some of you have
to pull the parking brake and the
hydraulic brake
well this one i wasn't used to so i go
up to the top of this hill and there's
the bin you know we get all the nails
and all the [ __ ] for the framers so i'm
getting all the [ __ ] for the framers i
walk into the bin and i [ __ ] come out
and go who the [ __ ] took my petty bone
bro the mexicans are pointing at it
they're like your petty bones down here
bro i forgot to put on the break the
thing went backwards dude down this hill
almost took out a house took out this
masonry wall and i i was like dude this
is gnarly dude and i look at the
pedigree the wheels are all [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] and then
dude it was like the boss i see the boss
coming up the hill with this truck
i'm like bro i didn't know i forgot to
put the hydraulic brake on he goes
here you go sean i think it's it's time
for you to
to um
take you know
to beat it
he's like beat it kook and i was like
[ __ ] yeah unemployment summer time let's
go
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]